thank you
good evening councilors can I ask you to
take a seat please
well good evening and welcome members
officers and those members of the public
here at the meeting and those joining us
virtually
item one on the agenda is apologies
thank you chair apologies from councilor
Lauren bright councilor Annie Brenton
and councilor David Brenton councilor
Simon Newton and Council machine Thomas
the item two uh public contributions
we've got four public speakers this
evening and the first one is Mr John
Lewis who I'll now invite to come up to
the front Mrs
chat here okay
Mr Mike here
hmm
public speakers get three minutes from
the time they start to uh
speaking like so if we did they might
just behind you there okay
very good you've got three minutes we
start when you start
okay good evening everybody your name my
name is uh Mike Mike tier and I'm the
chair of way of the Wolves local charity
two weeks ago Heritage organizations
along the torrage got together to
discuss their common interests
and the meeting really came about
because of the publicity surrounding
leveling up and funds and discussions
with Jeffrey Cox MP but it quickly
became apparent
but whether there was any leveling up
phones or not
we had more to gain by being together in
that group
it now represents 10 local charities and
Community interest companies
and that's over 2 000 members
and of those two thousand members and
supporters 200 are volunteers
these are the people who are chipping
the paint
and putting on paint on carriages
and welcoming people into the Burton
gallery or onto SS fresh spring
all of those people who are really
really doing the work
and the first thing that we all agreed
we can come together on is the
application for Heritage Harbor status
and that's been led by way of the wars
but it's not just us that's doing it
Heritage Harbors are a joint initiative
from the maritime Heritage Trust and
National Historic ships
and there's currently 10 in the Country
Three Inland ports on canals and seven
ports the closest to us being Exeter
and I was at
for Marathon Festival in exetera last
weekend
and I watched
Britannia a 108 year old fishing boat
that was restored in winklingman being
put into the water in Exeter why in
Exeter because Exeter were desperate to
get some Heritage ships in their Harbor
there's no application or ongoing fee
for Heritage Harbor status but there are
certain obligations
researching and Publishing about the
Heritage significance of the port
publishing an asset register of historic
buildings and vessels
identifying skills that are used for the
upkeep of heritage
identifying stakeholders
speaking and I quote from local
community and or Council meetings
take
establish a website and all the other
things that go with it
but the way of the Wars project and its
work on the history of the wars East the
water is the proven model the Heritage
Harbor and nearly there Mr near me okay
thank you
so the vision is to create a partnership
organization that can pull together
common message and promote the range of
Maritime and Industrial Heritage
attractions along the Estuary from
applegore all the way to Torrington the
end of the liquid Highway at the end of
the Royal Canal
please to support Heritage Harbor
whether that be
just supporting it but also obviously
through funding and support for the many
volunteers that pull this sort of thing
together
thank you thank you very much
very generous with you now thank you
well our next speaker is uh John Puddy
thank you very much do you know the
score at all yeah it's three minutes
Sean from when you show us me no
shouting no swearing and no abuse anyway
well thank you very much for letting me
speak to you this evening my name's John
puddian I'm the chair of the steamship
fresh spring Trust
um our heritage ship thanks to the
support of tourist District Council has
been here since
2016 supporting some 50 volunteers
The Freshman trust has been successful
in our district
supporting the education of young people
and enhancing tourism
however it has been expected to pay for
commercial birthing
and access charges for its nationally
recognized ship a situation which is
very difficult to sustain
the potential now Kathleen and May and
other Heritage vessels being based in
beautiful is becoming more of a reality
and it's important that TDC recognizes
the impact and the potential for a
Heritage breed is appreciated and
supported
particularly within its strategic plan
it's not possible to contemplate
bringing other ships to a bit of food of
concessions and support is not available
from our Council
a decision must be made to either
embrace the opportunity that Heritage
tourism could bring as other areas have
done
or possibly losing Heritage shirts for
good
our deprived area of statements is
unfortunate but provides opportunities
for leveling up funding and other
funding sources
which were the Visionary Council and the
connected Community we should do all we
can to access
the Strategic plan should reflect the
importance of Heritage and Heritage
tourism
in creating high quality all year round
the regulatory Heritage Group which Mike
has mentioned is embracing most local
Heritage organizations
both Maritime and terrestrial
who all have an aim to become
stakeholders in supporting any
application for funding
the Torres District Council believes
will support the four metrics within the
proposed leveling up funding or indeed
any other application which elevates our
important and valuable local heritage
our aim is not to compete but to fully
support our Progressive local Authority
in its vision for the future
to include business opportunities
skills retention and valuable high
quality Heritage tourism
I urge counselors when determining the
Strategic plan to think positively of
the future of our district
and to embrace the vision of a heritage
port
Heritage interpretation
Heritage tourism
retention of skills and to embrace a
future with Heritage ships in our Harbor
thank you very much
thank you John
exactly the same time as a breather
speaker well done
okay we've got Tim stearnex you know to
come up to
if we want
[Music]
to support thank you chair my name is
Tim steer I'm the vice chair of the talk
of rail Association and also one of the
directors of Biddeford Railway Heritage
Center
many members will recall uh the
presentation which I gave to all Council
last April and the update reports on the
joint planning obviously committee last
July
that joint meeting highlighted
resolutions of both north Devon and
orange district councils and the
recommended that the Joint Committee
required officers to ensure that
consideration of including a new Rail
Link Between Biddeford and Barnstable to
be explored and embedded within the work
program the new local plan project
since then an independent specialist
transport advisor has been commissioned
and completed an initial business case
report which is then being considered by
its client body the talk arouse location
and a published summary which was
reported to Biddeford Town Council in
the company of Sir Jeffrey Cox KC on
Thursday the 3rd of August
it is recognized that most no more than
700 meters of a new realm link between
Biddeford Advanced school would be
physically in the greater Biddeford area
and torrage District nevertheless
District boundary proximities play
little in why Railways are reinstated
Railways are now restored to serve
communities in districts and large
connovations just look at the District
of West Devon in 2021 they had the UK's
first restored Railway service naming it
the Dartmoor line to okehampton the line
has now received leveling up the funding
for a second part way nearer to the
district of mid Devon and now business
case has been presented to the
department for transport to reinstate
tab stop to Bear Alston aligned nearer
to Paul Wall the Biddeford Railway
Heritage Center has Ambitions to play
its part in the new level in our
partnership by seeking to support and
develop a project that at the time will
expand its visitor offer and physically
expand its operations into an initial
step to protect the site for a future
modern rounding towards Barnstable in
that respect the project would aim to
align with our economy and our
environment our future feeds is a
strategic plan and so far as possible at
least some of the poor keep leveling up
criteria and some of the 12 missions set
out by the government's leveling up
white paper in February last year
tarkano Association and Biddeford
Railway Heritage Center look forward to
collaborating and support the new
strategic plan and in the new leveling
up partnership thank you
languages
100 times as well
okay items three uh on your agenda
there's Declarations of Interest
remembers an interest in declaration
refer to the gender item and describe
the nature of the arrangements being
discussed
item for an agreement a general items
part one and two ordinal part two items
this evening
and writing five to consider cost
Anonymous around the business board
followed by the chair I have nothing
specifically in The Yards yeah
so moving on then to item six uh the
Taurus strategic plan
23 to 28 in this Pages three to ten
and you're back
you'll receive a report of the leader of
the council
and the chief executive
ah thanks thanks share I'm going to
start and just go a quick brief
introduction uh John altazon gonna run
through a little bit of where we've come
from what we're doing and where we go
next what's he assuming you approve the
the drop plan this evening and then from
the original leader the council kind of
again change to the rapid wrap up the
discussions
um obviously it's quite a quite a short
report
um but a significant piece of work and a
significant step forward for this new
Council
um obviously being elected back in May
of this year uh So within just under
five months she already got and set out
your draft Ambitions for the next uh
three and a half years I guess till May
27 although the plan as you'll see it
goes on until uh 2020 page
um so that will give three I said three
and a half years to get those plans in
place start and implementing uh your
vision your Ambitions for the council
um I guess it's really a good
achievement and really good to see so
many counselors at the workshop uh back
earlier in the year 30 members attended
that workshop and all our lead members
have been involved in the process after
that I look at the journal obviously
just stories
great inquired
um so it illustrates how important step
it is and how important here is to all
our members to get this up and running
so I'll hand over to John before I you
know any more videos
thank you
good evening cancerous
um
just going to give you a little bit of
background of how we got to where we are
today and then uh kind of the the
process for going forward did you uh
approve the documentation
um of the draft scrap plan for
consultation
so on the 31st of July uh full Council
agreed the timetable for
um the new strike plan uh and that
included a workshop on the 14th of
August that Steve mentioned which was a
really good turnout it's one of the best
we've had if not the best with 30
councilors attending that that gave all
all those 30 councilors the opportunity
to feed in to the building up of this
strategic plan looking at local
priorities
following that Workshop the leader and
myself have met with all uh the group
leaders uh no we didn't sorry about that
we met with all the League members of
the relevant relevant themes
um
for the Strategic plan and we went
through all of the information that
captured that was captured on the
workshop Steve Stacy Shawan and other
um senior officers also attended those
um those meetings but there was a the
leader on the south we attended all four
just so that there's some
um Clarity and continuity when we were
discussing
um the relevant information from the
beans so following those meetings a a
draft was put together which is on your
agenda now
uh that's Implement of you for for
um adoption to go out for consultation
what we've also got on your full Council
report is uh comments on each of those
League members so we've got 11 quotes on
there from The League members who were
involved following the uh Workshop so
the workshop we had 30 then we have all
the lead members
um
themed meetings
So today we're looking at the adoption
of the draft
for consultation
so if if approved tonight we've got the
comms team ready to go out to
consultation they will contact all the
parish in town councils all our partners
they've drafted a website they're ready
for the the
um social media homes they're going to
go in the local press as well for those
that aren't aren't online so we're kind
of ready to go provided it's adoption
we'll have six weeks consultation and
then once those uh responses are back
we'll to collate those and bring back to
a full pencil report on the 11th of
December we hope then to be in a
position for you to adopt your new
um strategic plan
um on that day
from that period your officers then will
look to put your priorities and your
actions into the business planning
process and link to the budget process
as well
so that's what will happen between the
11th of December and the 31st of March
and then from the first of April all of
those new actions will be aligned to
your qbr which is reported to internal
scrutiny it's monitored the actions are
monitored and they're they're all
successful pencilism
so that should then hopefully complete
the loop and then we'll be able to
Monitor and uh keep an eye on all the
actions that members have uh classed as
therefore she's going forward so that's
kind of an in a nutshell where we'll be
going just hand over to the leader
thanks for the James Mr finish off this
step for you
thank you John first of all I must thank
John because he's done a tremendous
amount of work and even last week if we
had one meeting in the morning he got
the information out in the afternoon I'd
also to point out that somewhere along
the line I was quoted in the paper this
morning about last night's meeting
you know the enthusiastic got the better
of some of our officers but
um I think it indicates how important it
is I'd like to thank all the members
that turned up to the workshop you know
we used to say that if we got 13 we
weren't doing bad we had 13 sounds
really good
um and also to all the lead members that
came to the the smaller sessions where
we went through
um What affected their Department what
they were the lead member for so it's
gone very well I'm going proud of you
all really my contribution was most you
can sit there in this one
um so there are any members and the rest
of you have all done the work
I think as John said we want to get it
out to consultation and I think the
thing about it is is it does set the
Strategic plan for them they'll come in
three and a half years and there's a lot
we want to achieve there's a lot we can
achieve that's what we should achieve on
behalf of our members you know that
that's what we're here for is to provide
a better environment in also
or descriptions of that word for our
members
um for our community and also I think
when Steve and I meet with the um yeah
that goes ahead the meeting with the um
Minister the stadium with 11 and up that
we can actually say we have a plan we
have the support of all our members and
that's important that we show that we
are on Council going somewhere
um and achieving a lot and I think
that's been one of my sight issues in
some cases where perhaps not everybody's
aspirations is quite as high level as
what ours are so I'll just thank you all
and propose that we do accept the
recommendation which is the three goes
out from consultation so thank you very
much
I know this has all been through the
filtering process of the members Etc
and we've all put in our ideas and this
is the proposed final document but under
the environment it's our future
um we've got the wording promote carbon
reduction and Energy Efficiency across
the existing Council asset phase well if
we're really serious as a council to
achieve that zero or by 230 I suggests I
suppose that we substitute the word of
dreams instead of the motor carbon
reductions that is about strong word and
then second advice to the public as we
go to consultation but we are serious
and that's why proposals
I see per second but thank you Peter I
think the aim of the consultation is
that everybody will be able to actually
uh you know come back with what they
want and if there is a stronger need to
emphasize something then that will come
out in the Constitution well in that
consultation sorry so yeah I'm fine well
it could create the consultation before
we get to it so this is what we've
assessed and you were in the Nations as
well so I I think that's great a
consultation out and then get the
reports back and you can report that
that and this is a draft document as
well
declare the climate emergency so we need
to be serious about it and I said I
can't remember what I suggested this of
the league member being seen or not but
I'm suggesting it now I mean it's just a
significant Small Change of working you
know
um seriousness
and I myself
or also failed I'm not I'm not prepared
to vote for this for our proposal
without the inclusion of social housing
in the housing Auditors because it does
not specify what range of things that
people
that we're looking to see I think it's
important that we include not just
affordable housing and other things that
we include social housing because that's
the single most important things while
functioning housing market
we don't allow people to have their
comments on social housing we won't be
getting a complete picture of what our
district needs
I'm just going to respond to that one
but we said this would all be
incorporated under a new housing
strategy so instead of going into the
the kind of my nishai the housing
strategy we'll have lots of different
strands and we said actually those type
of things will be covered when we go out
to consultation for that um and the
implementation of a housing strategy
uh yes I think that's that's really fair
and I have four or four foreign
represented you all but we needed a
robust housing strategies
for that document would actually
Encompass all aspects of provision and
social housing is one that has been
raised at every opportunity so of course
it will be included in that and that's
the time for us to accept
the housing strategy which will deliver
we can't go into every aspect
of how we're going to achieve better
opportunities to house our communities
in this corporate strategy this is an
overarching one and feeding into it will
be much more detailed strategies
so I share your issues and I understand
and councilor craiging but please be
assured that that will be dealt with
within that housing structure and it's
not in the distant future this is
something we will be working on very
soon
[Music]
housing be included in the options
and all it requires is on the first
point in housing
increase the availability and quality of
homes to meet local needs including
social housing
we've done within our room
sorry forgive me I don't want to have an
argument with anyone but if we look at
one particular aspect of housing
provision
what about low-cost home opportunities
for first-time buyers what about homes
that are suitably adapted for people
with disabilities we could catalog a
whole range of things which we hold dear
and we think are important so that is
why we're doing a collective
uh statement that these will be
considered in the housing strategy to
meet our local needs
um
Crystal you want to come in now yeah um
thank you
but no the plan as it stands
um I wanted to go back to what our
speakers said earlier they all referred
to the plan and they all refer to
leveling up
now we had
um Jeffrey Cox came along and talked to
a bit of a Town Council
and
I'm afraid it was a very good
presentation as you would expect from a
barrister unfortunately it seemed to be
completely wrong everything he said it
raised a lot of ideas and hopes that
don't seem to match the metrics since he
spoke and we've had these metrics which
don't seem to be what he was talking
about but what I want to ask is I see
that
the leveling up plan is going live in
March 2004 2024 according to our agenda
tonight
um at what point do counselors have
their input into this leveling up ideas
because
we were told Jeffrey said oh you've got
to have your plans in by March
you know it's got to be all costing and
everything and we thought what
we're all right we'll try it but now I
read what's going to happen I'll talk to
Chris Fuller and apparently it's not
going to all happen in one big bang
anyway it's going to be spaced out over
quite a long time but when do counselors
have their input into the leveling up
ideas which obviously feed into the
Strategic plan
yeah I guess that that's why it's in the
reports there's in the covering reports
Levina is referred to as part of the
covering report between the key feeds
through many or all of your themes so it
could be one or many so the first part
is getting your strategic Vision uh for
the district so we know the the high
level themes so below that there'll be a
range of projects so we'll be working
with uh civil servants to develop the
vision for the area this will form part
of that understanding the needs of the
areas so all the data that sits behind
all the metrics that have been
identified for storage as being a
leveling a partnership area and as we go
through that process we will then again
to understand what might be available
through the partnership so there will be
able to bring projects aspirations
policies to you for considerations part
to allowed to planning process so
there's no there's no specific steps or
details I'll search it's a new policy
and this one that's being developed
alongside and working with us so I can
just come back to that
um it actually said Steve
you'll come back to us with ideas and
all I ask about is when does counselors
have their room
that's not that's what I kind of say we
like the Strategic plan we'll be working
with you as councilors to develop those
ideas and this is part of that process
I'm just coming there and just say
at the moment
we don't honestly know that we're going
to get a pound or 20 million or what the
criteria is going to be and that's why
Steve's already had an initial meeting
with a
um elect I can't say a journey a member
of the council but uh the government
that must have a meeting with a civil
servant the aim of us meeting with the
minister and it was going to be Dionne
Davidson but it won't know it's going to
be Jacob young is to find out
within the strategy we're trying to get
underway and I bought it forward a month
I think we're so nervousness about doing
it because I wanted to get on with it I
didn't want us to be running into next
year and still clapping about we want to
get the consult concentration out of the
way and some idea where we were going in
person but the point is until we really
know what this has aimed up we're not
sure we've got ideas and some of them
are fairly obvious but until we actually
know what the minister is looking for
and we all know our ministers will
change on a whim
um so it's very difficult but we won't
be deciding where we go we will be
putting some of the ideas forward that
the minister agrees are within the
Matrix of what they've offered us it's
so good let's go into in with loads of
member ideas from the council and for
members and the minister saying well
that doesn't create anything go away and
come back when you've got some idea what
you're talking about about we have got
to get and build a pattern of how we see
college going forwarders this isn't in
isolation this is a strategic plan to do
with the growth of college we've got the
local plan going on which we're looking
at how we deal with housing and all the
planning issues we've got a housing task
force that is looking at cadaver which
is looking at the types of photosyn
including community housing and social
housing and all that and we've also got
the Devon Futures which is looking at
skills and education so we've got all
that going on what we need to know from
the minister is where the focus is what
does actually qualify us for this money
and then we can come sit all around and
decide is that what we want is that
where we're going but we just seemed to
be wanting to put the cart before the
horse and come up with ideas of what we
want with no idea whether the
government's going to accept them ideas
things
and the more you do that the more
ridiculous we will look and the less
likely we are to get that money it's got
to be what the government's aim is
against what our aim is and what we know
our aim is to lift the economy their
education
improve housing all of that
and that's what all of us want and
certainly why I'm there is to improve
the area and to give our communities a
much better chance particularly our
young people you know the old idea they
go away they get educated they find good
jobs and come back now we want a
strategy that delivers everything that
so our young people can stay here they
can have good jobs and we can actually
promote the economy you know don't
forget why we're getting that money it's
because we're a deprived area
so we won't spend hours debating on why
we're at a private area we're going to
start looking at what we can do to get
over that situation and go forward so I
think you know let's not deal with
detail let's get the Strategic plan
underway as Steve said there will be
loads of meetings although we're a
little bit unsure until we talk to the
minister about that end of March day and
how it will fit in because they won't be
dealing with every concert at the same
time but we're hoping because we're
being classified as the bride that we
will get fairly early by hour and the
same applies to a Devolution you know
it's
everybody wants a wish list we can't
deliver it with this and if we go with a
wish list we won't get anything we have
to go with a strategy of how we're going
to improve this area that's what all our
aims should be so put your effort into
consultation and then when we move on to
doing discussions about what we're
looking at put your effort into that
don't start getting distracted by
individual small detail
I just like the second the motion
um I think it's a good foundation for us
to get moving I think you know we need
to start moving on this so I second
abortion and it'll go through thank you
thank you concerning
so the recommendation is
um it's a draft strategic plan 2012 yeah
I didn't realize you're taking that I
thought yours is a separate question
I've been second it and then ready
the two proposals chair which I put
forward in Council crazy
concentrating proposed adding sexual
housing if he wants to go in in the back
where it says develop and then the
question of Craig is who's second the
country I was just going to say our
secondary secondary area sorry I'm just
trying to if Council Craig is willing to
change his proposal to point but
including social housing after the
developer that Implement a housing
strategy that lives
so there's two proposals to
I belongs one proposal for you councilor
Haynes which was
um substitute achieve instead of promote
and Council craving and seconded that
but what I wasn't clear on with that
proposal was if you were then opposing
the whole plan as it is with that
Amendment
and then councilman craigie then came
forward with a different proposal which
was to include social housing
yeah he's just saying people agreeing to
on the developmental housing strategy
yeah okay yeah okay cultural Ames is the
amendment has been proposed and seconded
so whatever show of hands in support of
cultural changes
foreign
under Peter haynes's guidance I changed
to put including social housing in the
Implement and housing strategy that
provides Creative Solutions that leave
the housing needs is included in social
housing well that's separate from yeah
please
vote
like I have a short hands and catchers
reportable show fans in support of that
place
a pencil and recorders
okay councilor Andrew
councilor back
let's stay
that's the Chris bright
that's the bushby yes
councilor Christie or
perhaps with Cotter pumpkin
or
[Music]
Dart yeah
councilor Elliot yes
thanks uh Gibson again
councilor God for
councilor Hackett against
Chancellor Haynes or councilor Harding
again
Council Hawkins oh
that's a heple against
councilor Hicks okay
that's not Hudson and
that's the inch again
councilor James and James councilor
Johns engage councilor leather yes
or
that's the piper I'm sorry
Bachelor Smith I'm saying
that's the weekly so
that's Lewis Cup against
that's eight and four but being against
and six absentions too
amendment is clearly lost I know he's
got to come on
[Music]
um
we have improved plants that hangs his
amendments
surely by just simply changing one word
there are implications in changing that
one word
and the actual meaning of what it means
to achieve
um problems
um
there are implications from just
changing one word on the rest of the
strategy particularly the ones that
refer to the financial implications and
the spending I agree country
no we haven't we have not voted we have
two
foreign
strategy
as a member
so it needs to be born in mind that
there is a bigger implementation than
just simply changing one word on this
entire strategy
you don't seem to realize the
implication of what you're saying I do
if we all if we don't vote for this
because you don't like our memories
we've had this extraordinary meeting in
order to get his strategy fit with the
timetable this will throw it back
another six weeks just for one word and
really and truly councilor Hayes put his
finger on it when he said we have
declared a climate emergency now some
people may think well we've declared it
tick that's all right we've done that
but we actually have to show we're doing
that and that's why it's a very simple
amendment I couldn't see any problem
here with myself but I've been very much
[Music]
um elongate the debate but that word
achieve you could achieve a one percent
reduction it doesn't necessarily mean
you'll achieve carbon reduction to zero
right so I don't know if that helps onto
the diet
myself fine but it's not that I don't
like the amendment I think there is a
bigger picture here and if you only wish
to achieve a one percent reduction then
with an expensively that whole
proposition was not worth the time and
effort we've been put to it so exactly
are you hoping to gains and changing
that word and if you're not going to
then amend the rest of the um financial
implications to achieve that then it
makes a mockery of what you've just
voted on
to put that together then you really
should have thought about this before it
came together
and I just like to say that I think
um the amendment proposed is a
consideration of what I've seen as an
excellent process
we're at a strategic level
you've been made aware that
um this will feed into business
Advantage I think it was
engaged in
but also point out that the council in
in their priorities
um align the cancerous activities to
meet the carbon neutral operation Target
of 2013. this is a plan for five years
which takes us scary in 2028
if we're merely promoting at this stage
and you're actually doing here I think
that has an absolute logic
and it I think we have to remember that
we are not taught in operation yet we
are talking to index which I will admit
I just struggles sometimes to get like
evidence back I think it was really bad
but because of the post actually bonds
would I feel I've been able to finish a
team with me the people I just sat down
this have been thinking members and
offices and I think we need to get on
and go forward with what we've all been
expecting thank you okay well you've
given us a
sorry democracy
I'll just point out if it helps
councilor down on page six of your
agenda tonight implications
and it says their financial implications
there are no specific financial
implications at this time
right okay it's been proposed and
seconded that we accept this graph draft
I emphasize where draft strategic plan
23 to 28 and it's published for
confrontation it's performed by
counselor James seconded by cancer
horroring show of hands all in support
peace
and against
on abstentions
2074-1 against the one I'm sorry
thank you
okay moving over to item seven revenues
and benefits document Imaging process
I upgrade and Conference conversion
Pages 11 to 30 new agenda if you receive
the report of head of legal and
governance thank you thank you and so
hopefully this will be a little less
contentious
so this has only been to CNR will
approved by um CNR but effectively
um all documents that come into the rubs
and Ben's team are scanned in and
uploaded to the customer file
um so historically we would have paper
files or course put on there and
obviously through the years we've
upgraded to an online system and the the
benefit of that is
um when a customer telephones
um the team are immediately able to tap
into their files and all the associated
documentation
um that's the system that they currently
use is no longer going to be supported
um so we've got to upgrade for security
reasons
um and to make us safe through data
protection gdpr all of that
um the reason it's at ball council
tonight is because of the upgraded costs
which are are more so it's a capital
um expenditure
um but as you'll see from the report the
ongoing
um maintenance charges that are actually
significantly less for us so
um currently with the current system we
spend 37 000 or nearly 38 000 pounds per
annum
um the annual maintenance license fee
for the new system will be six thousand
six hundred
um but there is the one-off
implementation charge which is a capital
bid of 35
000 and a one-off license charge of 33
um which is why it's for you before you
tonight to to approval or not approve
that that is always the case may be but
happy to take the questions
students relatively straightforward to
me we're going to save some money
any questions
all in favor please show
be anonymous thank you
that brings us to the end of the meeting
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
for your participation